le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
dans le domaine sportif
la réunion est une île dynamique un
vivier de jeunes champions des talents
qui se révèle dès l'adolescence et
parfois dans le milieu scolaire
fabrizzio saïdi a découvert le sport au
collège en unss
aujourd'hui il bat des records de course
au niveau local et vice champion de
france sur le 200 m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une démonstration de force un
cocktail de rapidité de détente et
d'endurance
en avril dernier la ville de l'étang
salé a accueilli son premier meeting
international d'athlétisme aux côtés des
sportifs médaillés et internationaux des
jeunes espoirs réunionnais comme
fabrizzio saïdi 18 ans encore élevée à
47,5 au corps de l'araignée deux
catégories confondues j'ai commencé en
sixième en fait on faisait des cross du
collège et chaque année je gagne en fait
le premier en famille mais pas lui car
c'est grâce à l'union nationale du sport
scolaire unss que le jeune homme se
révèle et c'est ici au collège des
tamarins à saint-pierre qu'une nouvelle
histoire s'écrit pour fabrice diot la
première fois qu'il passe les grilles de
l'établissement
c'est encore un élève turbulent et
dissiper
grâce au sport il apprend la discipline
et la persévérance et s'illustre
rapidement jamais il m'a dit les gens
mardi il avait un club d'athlé à les
partager et m'a dit de me renseigner
jean marc m'a dit que j'ai du talent et
il faut travailler ce talent là pour
être fort quoi c'est parti aujourd'hui
fabrizzio n'est plus au collège mais il
continue de s'entraîner avec son coach
l'ischio va s'étirer presque tous les
soirs avec les membres de son club
il repousse ses limites dans la crise
dans l'arc jeux d'eau dans laxe voilà on
est gagné pour jean marc hardy très
impliqué dans le développement de la
discipline
l'urss est une porte d'accès vers le
sport de haut niveau c'est un petit peu
le lieu où tous les élèves de tous les
établissements scolaires de l'île se
rencontrent
sur le plan sportif et c'est vrai que il
ya un gros brassage et qui est beaucoup
de gamins qui découvre le sport à
travers lui ai dit et en plus ici à la
réunion l'urss est extrêmement dynamique
on a le record je crois de collège qui
partent au championnat de france
mais au-delà de l'aspect sportif il ya
vraiment la volonté chez tous les les
collègues qui s'investissent dans l'urss
la volonté de former des citoyens formez
des hommes
laisse-moi élastique là tout contrôle
voilà le département gestionnaire des
collèges de l'île participe
financièrement aux actions de l'urss
ce département est aux côtés des
sportifs
depuis le plus jeune âge à travers
l'urss à travers l'aide qu'on apporte
bien sûr la pratique sportive sur l'urss
il ya un financement pour accompagner
depuis le plus jeune âge le jeune
jusqu'au haut niveau à travers un
financement de 2 millions 117 1000 euros
par an
donc on donne l'aide au fonctionnement
au club et aussi l'aide sur des projets
on accompagne aussi les ligues et les
comités et on donne aussi une aide pour
l'épaule qui recentre donc tous ses
talents pour les emmener au plus haut
possible
plus haut plus loin plus vite
aujourd'hui
fabrizzio vise une place en équipe de
france il s'entraîne près de dix heures
par semaine tout en poursuivant ses
études il a neigé le bac en plus
ou pour un peu d'organisation
l'élève agité est aujourd'hui loin
derrière lui resté sur la touche pour
laisser place à un athlète déterminées
donnent une nouvelle vision je suis là
aujourd'hui que je fais plein voyage que
je vais j'ai fait un stage récemment en
afrique du sud par en france deux fois
ou trois fois par an et tout ça c'est
grâce à l'unicef une démonstration sur
400 m il ya quelques instants il est là
dominique est des records personnels 21
c'est le report de la réunion fabrizzio
servi pour moi en fait la clé
j'ai trouvé pas ça intéressant en fait
quand j'étais petit je me demandais en
fait derrière quoi ces gens qu'on en
fait et aujourd'hui j'ai compris
on court après le temps
[Musique]
l'urss et l'union nationale du sport
scolaire son objectif organiser et
développer la pratique sportive en
milieu scolaire unss et ouverte à tous
les élèves du second degré au collège
son financement est géré par le
département via la direction de
l'éducation
le conseil départemental propose aussi
plusieurs autres subventions et consacre
chaque année 2 millions cent dix sept
mille euros au domaine sportif
pour plus de renseignements sur ces
aides vous pouvez consulter le site du
département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]